well i think you you just add to that
this weekend that uh you say okay the
raiders are two and oh
and now they have a short week sunday
game across the country against the
patriots and
the patriots are uh
look i know that the patriots gave up
whatever 35 in seattle
on sunday night
but that defense
if i am john gruden and i'm watching
tape
i am looking and seeing how much
pressure they got on russell wilson for
four quarters
and the reason that seattle put up 35 is
that russell wilson is one of the best
players in nfl history
not just today in nfl history at
throwing the ball accurately downfield
under pressure
that is what they're going to need this
week if they win this game
you know john gruden is going to need
derrick carr to make two or three throws
with lawrence guy or chase winovich or
or you know a a devin mccourty a safety
blitzing
they're gonna he's gonna have to make
some of those plays for the raiders to
win that to me is a really fascinating
matchup
just because on the surface you say wow
raiders you know got a great chance
going into new england and i agree they
got a really good chance going into new
england but what would scare me is just
the simple fact
that derek carr is gonna have to make
big plays with people in his face
well that's right and the question is
peter will he throw it down the field
when the opportunity is there that's one
of the criticisms that chris sims
circles back to from time to time he'll
have the shot he won't take it and chris
knows from experience specifically the
experience of
playing for john gruden he wants you to
take those shots when they're there and
he wants you to know the difference
between when they're there and when
they're not there
and you know when you look at the
seattle new england game the shots could
be there because they were there for
seattle but i think it's going to be
even more dangerous and it may make carr
even more hesitant because he's going to
know stefan gilmore is going to want to
make up for a bad showing against dk
metcalf so
derek carr is going to really have to
push himself to just cut it loose and i
think the mindset for this game is we
got nothing to lose we're 2-0 that's
money in the bank no one expects us to
go to
new england and win this game let's go
out and let's try to take it and that's
the only and that's what you know gruden
can show in the film over and over again
of russell wilson this is what you have
to do to beat the patriots dink and dunk
is not going to beat the patriots you
got to take your shots when you have
your shots and it's up to you to know
when you have that opportunity and not
hesitate and get rid of the football and
hope for the best
mike you know there's one other game
this weekend that no one is going to
call the game of the weekend in fact
it's a matchup of 202 teams
but to me
one of the fascinating matchups this
weekend
is a beat up mentally and physically
philadelphia eagles team hosting joe
burrow in the bengals because we saw
last week
joe burrow these are not your father's
bengals
you know the these are not the david
klingler bengals they're not even the
andy dalton bengals in my opinion
this is an explosive offense that's
going to come into philadelphia
and philadelphia
certainly doesn't look explosive on the
other side i mean you know no jalen
rhaegar this weekend probably i i don't
know about al shawn jeffrey but
obviously he hasn't played yet this year
you don't know what you're gonna get and
so i kind of look at this game and plus
everybody is piling on with carson wentz
and rightfully so he has not played well
this you look on the surface the eagles
have to win this game they absolutely
unequivocally have to but you know what
joe burrow doesn't give a blank
about what the philadelphia eagles need
you know he's gone into tuscaloosa and
whacked the crimson tide so going into
philadelphia with no fans i doubt it's
going to scare him very much
but peter that's the mentality
that joe burrow has that will serve him
well throughout his career and that's
the mentality derek carr needs because
you know to me this is his opportunity
this is his year this is it
john gruden keeps seeing these young
quarterbacks come into the nfl and
they've got the skills they've got the
mindset they've got the moxie they've
got everything and eventually he's going
to say i need one of those guys if my
guy won't play like these young guys who
maybe don't know any better to be more
hesitant about cutting it loose i'm
going to go get one of these young guys
and we're going to push derek carr down
the road to wherever it is that he goes
next in his career and that's just the
reality so there is a connection because
joe burrow would throw the ball down the
field against new england patriots and
derek carr this is his chance to show
that he's willing to roll the dice that
he's willing to throw an interception if
that's what happens that he's willing to
take the chance because that's the only
way you're going to beat the patriots if
you go out there and take the chance
couple of injury notes from that game
that are going to be potentially
impactful as it relates to the raiders
offense darren waller tight end didn't
practice thursday he had 12 catches
against the saints on monday night and
josh jacobs who was a battering ram for
the raiders especially in the second
half keeping the saints offense off the
field he didn't practice either so if
either of both of those guys aren't
available peter it becomes a lot harder
to take care of the meat and potatoes
stuff that allows you to set up those
shots down the field
yeah and look
you know derek carr is such an
interesting
uh test case basically for john gruden
in his career because i think he really
wants derek carr to work but
then what happens is
john gruden goes and works out kyler
murray personally in texas you know a
year ago and it i never forget at the
combine a year ago when we didn't really
know what the raiders were gonna do
uh and and one of the coaches uh who i
know who knows grudenwell said you
realize john gruden's favorite
quarterback i said who he goes the one
he doesn't have
and so
those are the kind of things that if
you're derek carr you just have to be
conscious of it you can't let it rule
your life because then you're not going
to be able to perform but you have to
understand that every week
you step into john gruden's test kitchen
that's something sims has said over and
over again john gruden is a quarterback
hoarder now sims
unfortunately says it a different way
and he thinks that's the right term
and i've had to tell him it's [ __ ]
durr chris there's a dir that has to go
to the end of that but yeah it's always
that wandering eye it's always that
fascination and chris has been that guy
who i thought i was your starter and
gruden's always looking around he always
wants to upgrade at quarterback and and
i think this is the year that he will if
he doesn't get what he wants out of
derek carr all right uh one of the guys
that i'm sure john gruden would love to
have are the two quarterbacks playing on
sunday in seattle dak prescott or
russell wilson either one yes thank you
very much i would take them if i'm john
gruden um this one has the potential
peter to be
just you know an nba style
game from a scoring standpoint because
the defenses haven't shown they can put
the clamps on anyone and the offenses
have shown they can't be clamped
and i think that's going to be the way
this game is going to be played
i was telling somebody in dallas
yesterday that i said i don't bet on
football i don't bet on anything but
if i bet on anything this year
uh in the nfl
i said i don't even know what the over
is in this game but i would bet the over
unless it's like 75 points
and uh and so
that's what i think you're going to see
because
that's how each of these teams right now
while the respective defenses are
settling in that's how they have to play
and here's the one other thing so
the dallas cowboys have got to get more
pressure from that defensive front
uh that's why they brought in everson
griffin that's why they bought brought
in al alden smith first week of the
season they got great pressure they need
to get more pressure consistently from
that front because you've got to
understand after you lose byron jones
you know their secondary is very much a
work in progress their front really has
to help him especially against a
quarterback like russell wilson who is
just totally not intimidated by anything
so he's going to make his plays
downfield you've got to do everything
you can to try to sack them five or six
times
the best way to slow down a high-powered
offense is to keep it off the field
cowboys coach mike mccarthy told
reporters yesterday they won't go into
slow it down mode to try to limit the
number of opportunities that russell
wilson may have and i i don't know how i
feel about that because you have you
have a guy you have a guy you have a guy
in ezekiel elliott you can grind it out
with him just you know even if your play
calling doesn't change just the
awareness
of when the clock is running taking the
full 40 seconds before you snap the ball
the next time
that that to me seems to be a prudent
way to deal with russell wilson but i
think that at one level mccarthy doesn't
want to concede that that his offense
isn't every bit as good as seattle's and
it's going to be those whoever has the
ball last type of a games where uh you
know it's going to be close right down
to the wire and we'll see who makes the
last shot
mike you know look you can be a coach
and you have to say that you know you
have to say it because
you want your players to know that you
are all in with them
so
that's totally understandable but then
you know
i would bet and and again i i don't
let's see what happens i would bet
that mike mccarthy
uh and the dallas cowboys kellen moore i
bet they call fewer
out routes uh corner routes than they
normally might in the course of a game
and they call more crossers more curls
uh more intermediate stuff over the
middle of the field because
they want to keep the clock running and
you have to be cognizant of that against
russell wilson
if the cowboys give russell wilson eight
possessions they got a really good
chance in this game if they give him 11
possessions
i i i mean i think it's seattle's game
yeah it's going to be a great game
potentially and you've got two of the
mvp candidates right now russell wilson
is the favorite after a couple of weeks
he said yesterday he doesn't just want
an mvp vote he wants the mvp he may get
all 50 votes by the time it's said and
done this year if he keeps it up but dak
prescott is in the conversation as well
and you know peter we we spend
the season
talking about the mvp candidates because
people are intrigued by they're
fascinated by it the reality is at the
end of the day when the season is over
and we know the two number one seeds in
each conference and especially now that
the one seed means more than ever before
because only the ones he'd get to buy
it's going to be the quarterback of one
of the one seeds unless the quarterback
is just a bystander that's going to be
the key unless there is
a ridiculously over-the-top
record-setting type of a performance
from another quarterback
it's going to be the quarterback of one
of the one seeds because that that seems
to be the default choice that uh it is
mike but
but i'm gonna i'm gonna disagree with
you on that okay because my feeling is
that let's just say that the way this
season
gets played
that we look at the nfc west as maybe
the best division of the last 10 years
and and who knows what's going to happen
but right now it's seven and one
and you know if you had to pick a team
that today this moment is the worst team
in the division as nutty as it sounds
it's the 49ers you know because they're
playing nick mullins and and all this
but
but i guess the point i'm making is
you know if russell will if the seahawks
are let's say the third seed after a
total civil war of a year in the nfc
west and russell wilson for the first
time in his life has thrown for 5 000
yards and he's thrown 38 touchdowns and
six interceptions and you know he's
brought the seahawks to a two-game
margin in the toughest division that
we've seen in years in the nfl
that's going to hold some sway with me
and i i understand exactly what you're
saying
but i think
the more the more i look at the mvp
voting over the years yes the top seed
teams the top couple of seeds they have
a huge advantage when it comes to the
mvp vote no question about it but i also
think that you have to look at every
factor
and this year one of the factors is
going to be the armageddon schedules
that teams like the seahawks face
but here's the thing too to get back to
the point we were making last hour about
that that spin of the wheel that
determines half of your schedule every
year the four nfc west teams play the
four afc east teams and the four nfc
east teams and that's one of the things
that sims and i put a flag in the ground
over in the off season and i see others
are starting to warm up to this
possibility with three wild card spots
available there's a chance all four of
those teams of the nfc west will go to
the postseason this year which would be
unbelievable if it happened it's the
kind of thing i love to root for because
it's such a crazy outcome but right now
when you look at the second third and
fourth place teams in that division
versus the other three
top to bottom they're the best
yeah the the biggest problem is that
they're going to spend so much time
knocking each other off
and uh and then in an easier division
let's say in the uh in the nfc south if
tampa bay gets his at gets its act
together and wins 10 games look
i could be wrong mike i don't think four
teams in the nfc west are winning 10
games
but i do think that it
go ahead but you've got eight you've got
you've only got six of your games in the
division you've got eight of your games
against these two divisions that are
arguably the worst two in football
true
but what i'm saying is
look at going three and three or
one of those teams at least is gonna go
two and four in the division games
and what that means is theoretically i
would think if you go two and four in
those games then that means that in your
other games you're gonna have to go
eight and two to have a really good shot
to make the playoffs maybe seven and
three
but i i it's hard for me to believe that
that one
second place team in one of the other
divisions isn't going to win 10 games
and i i could be wrong but i i just
think that whether it's tampa you know
whether it's it's is one of the teams in
in the nfc uh in the nfc north like you
know chicago they go to atlanta i mean
would anybody be surprised if the bears
win this game and start and start three
and oh and
what that means mike
three and oh in the conference
also and you and i can argue about
trubisky all day but it doesn't matter
you're 3-0 with three conference wins
on december on september 28th
just the fact that we can even have the
beginnings of the conversation about the
nfc west sending all four teams shows
how good the nfc west is one of the
teams that may be jostling for wild card
position if the tampa bay buccaneers
wake up is the new orleans saints who
need to wake up after what we saw on
monday night in las vegas against the
raiders peter we haven't talked about
this
one of the popular narratives though of
the week drew brees is done it's over
it's finito as pat shurmur said uh a
year or two ago finito uh it i don't
think it's finito because i think that
drew brees is the same guy he's been the
last three years i think what's
happening is more people are starting to
notice it you know when the saints win
you don't notice that drew brees can't
throw the ball down the field
consistently
when they're down in the fourth quarter
and they don't have the punch to gain
yards in dramatic chunks to try to
narrow the deficit because the
quarterback can't throw the ball down
the field that's when all of a sudden it
becomes a major problem this is what the
saints have been the past few years so
where do you see this happening because
i think there's a chance it could go
haywire for the saints on sunday night
against the packers if the packers are
as good as they seem to be but i still
don't think the saints are fundamentally
lesser
or different from what they've been in
the past few years
yeah you know i looked at it a couple of
ways mike at the end of the first
quarter of this game
on monday
uh
i just thought oh my god i'll i'll be
and i'm exhausted monday night i'll be
able to go to bed at halftime
um
because the saints are gonna kill him
and obviously it didn't didn't happen
but i guess the point i'm making is that
i think if you watch the first three
drives let's just say and i i'm guessing
at that but you watch three the first
three three or four drives for the
saints and breeze is fine the offense is
fine
but
after a while you start to realize that
hey
michael thomas is really good
and remember last year mike we talked
about it on this show that sean payton
told me the great thing about michael
thomas is that with him the 50 50 balls
are 70 30 balls
and you know in his favor and all of a
sudden he's not there and you're asking
trequan smith
and a cast of just guys to be michael
thomas well i mean a lot of that is
going to go on drew brees shoulders and
to me unfairly i i'd say let's give drew
brees more than two shaky quarters
before we
uh uh start to uh put the spades in the
ground for him so to speak
one thing that's fascinating about the
saints this year they signed taysom hill
to the two-year 20 million dollar
contract with 16 million guaranteed and
they are using him
less than they used him last year he had
two runs for eight yards in week two his
snaps on offense were down his special
teams plays are dramatically down
against the vikings in the playoffs he
was involved in 84 percent of the
special teams plays on monday night he
was involved in 19 percent of the
special teams plays i feel like they are
semi bubble wrapping taysom hill whether
as a hedge against drew brees getting
injured or what i don't know but how do
you pay the guy that much money and not
use him for crying out loud he's capable
of being the best player on the field
that's a really good question mike and
you know i i go back to a couple of
years ago when on on a saturday night in
new orleans when
i was doing a story on the saints and
their multiplicity on offense
and i saw them in a hotel ballroom in a
walk-through on saturday night
uh and on one play
basically they lined up
and until it hit eight on the play clock
you know coming down you know ten nine
eight there was no quarterback on the
field
uh drew brees was split left taysom hill
was split right hill
basically then ran behind center took a
snap
and went wide right uh you know trying
to you know
that was going to be the play he was
going to run on this play so i think
that's a long way of saying essentially
that sean payton will keep his options
open and i believe he will have a role
increasingly
every week that he'll play more snaps on
offense taysom hill and he'll realize
that especially without michael thomas
he needs to use taysom hill more
particularly in the roles where he can
be a pass catcher
absolutely i was just stunned no balls
thrown his way last week no passes
thrown by taysom hill last week either
let's flip it over to the packers
the packers
created the impression based upon their
draft strategy that they were maybe
taking a step back
and planning for an opportunity to take
several steps forward in the future as
it turns out
they're a bit as good as they were last
year now it's possible that the vikings
in the lines are just absolutely
horrendous and the packers are going to
get their welcome to the 2020 season
moment on sunday night but this
matt laflore offense year two aaron
jones told me after the game on sunday
that the team is definitely better than
it was last year because they know the
offense they know the nuances they know
why they call these plays aaron rodgers
more focused because he understands that
offense unlike last year so i i look
that's why i think that there's a chance
that that this is what we saw monday
night magnified by virtue of the fact
that the packers are a hell of a lot
better than the raiders that the packers
are going to score and score and score
and can the saints match them but i i
don't i don't see that new orleans
defense being able to take a lot of the
steam out of this offense peter because
the new orleans defense wasn't able to
take the steam out of the raiders
offense
i mean he you know what really has
impressed me about the packers
and why i just totally give it up for
matt lafleur and aaron rodgers in
particular
uh look everybody i everybody on god's
green earth says okay
packers are going to take a step back
they are not as good as they were last
year blah blah blah blah they're not
going 13-3 again
and right now matt lafleur has coached
20 games in the nfl including in the
playoffs he's 16 and four
and this year so far the green bay
packers have scored 85 points in two
games and put up over a thousand yards
uh and and what that says to me
and i'll get to aaron rodgers but what
it says to me
is that
everybody in this organization brian
goodakins matt lafleur the players on
this team understand that drafting
jordan love didn't mean that we were now
looking at 2023.
drafting jordan love was the exact same
reason they drafted aaron rodgers in
2005. they want a succession plan in
place
and as brian guticunce told me
on sunday of draft weekend because i
said to him
you know that aaron rodgers you know
probably is going to take this as
supreme motivation what if he's great
the next three years and he goes well
that's good and i said what if you have
to trade jordan love he said well that
that's fine that'd mean we'd get great
quarterback play over the next three
years and into the future
that is why mike
everybody dismisses totally the prospect
that jordan love could be jimmy
garoppolo too
i don't dismiss it at all look at how
aaron rodgers is playing and and i'll
also credit aaron rodgers
tremendously
for coming into camp
without this sort of oh man i'm i'm i'm
angry at the world he he came into camp
with being the most uh
you know the most agreeable guy hey look
we're we're a great team we're this and
there was no anger
at anybody for drafting jordan love
instead of a wide receiver in the first
round
and so
that is why the packers are where they
are they've gotten buy-in from a guy who
you would thought maybe wouldn't buy in
aaron rodgers and he's playing the
football as as well as he's played in
recent years
it's a means to an end peter there's no
way he's forgotten about it i think he's
made the calculation that the best way
to deal with it is to be agreeable even
if it is a little passive aggressive and
to go out and kick ass and take names
and win games and win a championship and
then
hand the trophy to mark murphy the way
that paul crew handed the football to
the warden at the prison and say stick
this in your trophy case i'm out uh so
uh this
look somehow i don't see that happening
i hope the packers are great this year
and next year because i do think at some
level what the packers are trying to set
up is an opportunity to trade aaron
rodgers for a king's ransom at a time
when they otherwise would want to move
on from him anyway i think that's part
of the the method to this apparent
madness and i think mark murphy who's
got a lot more involved in football over
the past few years you know he liked it
last year when the tyler dunn story came
out painting a picture of dysfunction
between mike mccarthy and aaron rodgers
because maybe it'll get some people
riled up and when people get riled up
good things can happen the selection of
jordan love maybe it gets somebody even
more riled up and maybe some good things
happen for the packers so we'll see what
happens on sunday night i think there's
a chance peter that this one gets out of
hand i think there's a chance the
packers blow them out they're gonna have
750 fans there that's not nearly enough
to deter aaron rodgers when we saw what
he did in minnesota with no fans there
yeah well in a quiet superdome oh boy
again if it clicks like it has the first
two weeks watch out new orleans saints
all right